Ever since pool or billiards has existed, mathematicians and physicists have had these thought experiments about mathematical pool and mathematical billiards.
Because it's great for working out how a particle, or in this case, a pool ball, will rebound against the sides, and where it will go.
So I thought "enough of these thought experiments, lets build one!"
The shape is an ellipse, and ellipses are an interesting type of shape, because they can come in a infinite number of varieties.
The geometrical property of ellipses, which is why I made this table, is the fact that if you place a ball on a focus point...
...where ever you hit it, in which ever direction I hit it, over there, over there, over there, over there, over here,
it will always rebound into that pocket.
That is because from any point on the side, it makes the same angle to each focus point.
And as you know, when you rebound something against a surface...
... the angle of incidence equals the angle of reflection.
Whenever it is positioned on this focus point, wherever I hit it, it will go in.
If it's here, wherever I rebound it, it's never going to go in.
It's only when it's exactly on this dot.
So that's the theory, and that makes this really good fun.  I will demonstrate it.
But obviously I'm a mathematician and I love things to be perfect, but this is, we're in the real world...
...so now kind of annoying physics gets in the way.
Things like friction, things like the difficulty of manufacture.
You also have to hit it with just the right force.
For example, if I hit it really hard...
... it rebounds to this side of the pocket.
If I hit it, but softly...
... it goes to the other side of the pocket.
So obviously there is the Goldilocks hit, the one that's neither too hard nor too soft, that should get it in.
And let's see if I can do that.
If I do get it in, it's really difficult.
So you have to be very skilful.
Oh, beautiful!
It's so satisfying the way it goes round and round and round. It's reminding me I got it in.
Okay. So I chose to hit it over here.
We can nominate any other part of the board.
Again, it's going to be difficult because I don't have much time to practice on this.
I'm not a very skilled pool player.
But maybe something like...
Oh!
[Brady]: Take the camera.  I'll get my first ever shot.
It was quite..
Perfect!
At first I was a bit disappointed it was so difficult...
... and then I realized it's actually much better that it's difficult, because it's more more fun.
Starting from cuing off, you put the cue ball somewhere in the line between the black and here.
You've got to be thinking about this dot and how things would happen if they were coming from this dot.
I have to hit the black on this edge...